all right I was super quick I've never
seen hangouts like that we are both live
flashpoint with my Manny Bacchus what's
going on in uh you know just a good old
normal Friday morning get my early work
out and come back tidy things up and
then jump in the office for you know
this thing that we do yes sir you know
it's time man people are waiting in the
chat already so now they'll be in Austin
our key should I feel adjusting working
he was first in the champion all the
high train salute yeah he said something
last time he was like all my connection
diet is like well see if you can hold it
salad this morning no now graphic got it
said oh that's cool Fridays in a row
graphic I'm feeling special I'm feeling
nice new delve it was good awful yeah
been it's been good man it's been a good
week for destiny and getting something a
lot of games coming out man just get
that a Red Dead Redemption I did pick it
up I'm actually planning to play that
once and somewhere in between I'm trying
to keep up with the world of destiny but
it's one of those that's like so big and
it got reviewed so well I think I kind
of have to once I sort of ten I was like
masterpiece is coming out and I was like
yeah I'm like as a gamer I cannot not be
a part of the event cuz I was gonna wait
a little bit I can't wait like till next
week or something but once that you know
they started flying in and shout out to
my boy um MJ's a boss he said he's on
Twitter she's gonna be down with the
stream team soon and he was he was a
streaming a little bit last night so I
cross slip snippet of it and I'll just
like man this thing looks impressive you
know so yeah I'm all in man
well it Adele otherwise trot down I got
some little technical issues I gotta
sort out what mics up with digital
pre-order but other than that you know
I'll be ready to rock hopefully later on
and see what the big hop up is about
about the new potential game of the year
huh yeah I was like I'm gonna know after
playing God of War that's that a really
good bar for me just from like that was
that was a game that I did not expect
because I hadn't honestly played any
other ones and I know I missed out
people have enjoyed the series but that
one I
set the bar just for almost any game for
me this year's like just so well done
the story was good a little - it
actually made me want to learn about
Norse mythology I was like right now I'm
like yes so that was pretty cool and
then just a combat the level of
difficulty it came with just the it had
it did that Dark Souls thing to where if
you mess up you feel like it's your
fault
nakta game's not like it was a cheap
mechanic or not any ride it felt like it
was skill based and to me those are the
ones that I was like okay you guys
nailed up that's why Dark Souls it's
like they may be punishing but those
moments when you know you do it right
you're like I didn't drop the ball exact
finally you know I beat that mechanic
and I know it it I learned and all that
stuff and that's was like out of war on
top of the story like this the Sun
spoilers if you haven't seen it all
those little pieces like that was such a
well put together thing that's why I'm
kind of curious as this is just like
everybody's like well no game of the
year no question and it's it's rock
stars like I mean GTA 5 epic in scale
and like the biggest thing of all time
so I do afterwards
shoutout to graphic guy he said he was
gifted a right there to hold wife goes
out with her girlfriends today play-doh
del bowl a top of the morning to you sir
yes good to see you absolutely yeah we
got a lot going on this week man we got
we got some stuff to talk about we got a
lot of stuff talk about good solid table
I felt when I read reddit that late and
I know when you converse prior and um
yeah then we got speculation this is
juicy flashpoint man good week so far
just kind of kind of kind of tamed it
down a little bit last week was just a
little too much I think for everybody
and there was just like either weight on
iron banner or but it was this forest
iron banner and like shattered throne
just like all that stuff just kind of
lumped in together in one I mean here me
shattered throne so low like that
something's gonna take me like half a
day I mean that's gonna be a chunk I
mean some people may knock it out I was
like I got to Vora gas I kind of figured
out the damage phased pieces I just
didn't put together for run so I will
work on that next time for like solo I
mean I get the first I literally you
should see this thing
I literally drew a map of the first part
yeah so I know where everything's at
okay no this was that and I don't
remember how it was so I finally figured
out a system go get Tarot the deep in I
would just type myself in chat and be
like okay this symbol is over you like
dragon dragon fire right or something
like whatever my symbol is to myself and
then it would just you know double-click
check my chat again be like alright know
exactly where to run because I drew a
map and I know where to go and what
things are called knows like so I spent
the dumbass time to do that excuse the
language sorry
yeah it's just one of those was like I'm
gonna do this map now it's like what I
ever put that map on a video or
something probably do not probably need
to tweak it in at least Microsoft Paint
cuz handwritten is awful but yeah Shadow
Thrones cool but that in it along with
everything else was just too much last
week it was insane absolutely actually
gonna bleed into my topic because
obviously when we talked last flashpoint
you know I I made the strategic decision
that I wasn't gonna touch um you know
shut it throne and I wasn't gonna touch
umm festival because you know obviously
the tweaks to iron banner with all the
Cylons bounties giving powerful year I
just really dedicated myself towards
that while at the same time duplicating
taking care of my arm regex quest so I
was like getting like my long-term goal
and the short-term goal taken care of so
I did that I'll talk about the crucible
we'll get into crucible I got a lot to
say about that and they look
controversial I'm not that the I'll even
tell you talk about that the state of
the crucible but on yesterday this week
you know obviously banners are done
that's alright let me get in there and
touch on festival and I I literally just
felt like the very beginning spoke team
and did her little you know things that
she wanted me to do got my fighting lion
got the catalyst jumped in there yeah it
was I think I think you described it
perfectly last week because I mean when
I asked you to rank it because I never
played it and you said um you had it
right in the middle who said you
wouldn't put it over escalation protocol
but you have it over blind well and I
think I'm right there with you it's fast
it's fun you know you got to dam night
Mitch chasing you first time you say
that you're like invisible and then just
like yeah yes the kingdom comes out very
cool I like when you get you know each
level boss so to speak is a nightmare
and you get that going on you know and
they get you know more intense more
frantic I like that aspect and then to
me the ultimate role is that the end
when you get in the chest and it's like
yeah oh my god you might be in there
with invincible guy a few of them and
definitely will be trying that because
shout out I forgot my man last week in
sheriff got mad he put us on and he
would just like seven master work cause
I'm happy about that weekly bounty exact
we gotta get that weekly so that's
pretty much it for me you know just
prepping with that and like I said each
week taking it one at a time so that
that's that's the goal right now nice
well do you want to start with your
crucible topic because I know we can get
to the twelve but sure like I feel like
we just open it straight up kind of a
broad one so you just jump in and has
opened up alright his did like so
obviously you know we play a lot of
crucible with d2 at the start of d2 I
did not
and indeed one I used to play a lot so
for me I have some interesting
assessments and I want to talk to you
but see how you feel I don't know if you
play but I know you play PV mostly but
you know during the course of it you
know and I've going through a lot of
different weapon types archetypes trying
to find that good loadout shadow don'twe
car by - we've had some discussions like
this you know now the not at the meta is
settling I would say right when you say
the meta is settling he wants it's like
you know it's kind of inwards got your
Lunas house out there you know you've
got a lot of good weapons out there and
I've come a conclusion I was like I
first of all I had a lot of fun let me
just say that off top like doing banner
that whole week which is one of my
favorite of
you know I love the three lockdown
mechanic so much to the point that I
almost don't want to play control
without it like I love the lockdown
mechanic I just love it so um I'm with
you I honestly wish that was just there
yeah I just almost like control because
it adds such a different layer to
control Oh coach kkoma what's up salute
good to see um yeah so as like such a
different layer to it and it's trapping
what you can you can strategically make
comebacks cuz you like okay if we cap
now went down but we can still pull it's
just a tug-of-war giving ting so I got
that going on I played my favourite ball
got my bow he's got all my powerful gear
having fun and while I'm going through
it I'm like yo I gotta talk about this
meta and I want to bring it to your
attention because I'm gonna say
something very good Roger I think we'll
see as of right now destiny to crucible
meta is the best it's ever been and I
know I'm gonna get heat for this but I
really am lining the reason why I came
to that conclusion is this I said that I
can't record listen it's always gonna be
favorites right we went through the
thorn meta we went through um but you
know the normans mercy doctrine of
passing auto cirrhosis and the big super
rose had its met in the very beginning
um I'm the truth had a little fun and a
bit of a truth
hello fun we had three buckets I mean I
love truth very tracking rocket launcher
that's how it should feel
yeah last word you know but I always
felt in every matter that I've mentioned
you know felwinter's lie over that I
feel like every matter of wet mentioned
is always only been one to two dominant
weapons in said matter right in
this better I feel the TT K's are so
close for the most part when you have
like a God role go figure
you know you now I got my new baby right
now Claus in a wolf you know um I've
played with um what's cage weapon right
now am i flaking ok jeiza spades
I play with ace of spades with the radar
on sight you know the only negative I
could say about this meta is you can say
ok autos are not they're not terrible
but they're not dominant right I would
say oils are not dominant and it's
definitely a pulse rifle matter right
now I would say that but hand cannons
and I would say scouts out still right
scouts need help still I'll give you
that and autos Scouts would probably be
the only one you can say okay that's
borderline useless in this matter right
that's political networking powerful
what I also feel you're my surprise you
I've been right I got I've been rocking
grenade lon I feel grenade launchers are
better all Colonel insures honestly like
whatever they did but this would like
between a couple things those are what I
faced a lot of trash and all of a sudden
they're like they're a viable option if
you got proximity is legal cheating I
mean they're like grenades are
definitely a huge factor for sure right
I'm not a sword guy you know I know
swords got buffed in PvE but I'm not
seeing them in I'm not seeing them in
the crucible
I'll be at least when I play you know my
little sample size you know I'm gonna
put on for them I mean think about this
I've just named about like six or seven
type of weapon types right you know subs
you can make an argument your calls are
still good on side I feel sad arms or
above subs submachine guns sidearms are
good
subs not as much for some reason I'm not
seeing him I'm not using them I don't
know what that is and on console when
everybody ran to the new meta graviton
Manchester stronger for Everton Lancer
so strong I've seen people can kill with
it I've killed people with it yes it's
not the dominant thing you know I'm
saying saying with vigilance I feel they
just move from the very top to the
middle
right so on yeah suggesting wearing
auto-filled poop no I agree there but
you know why I don't have a problem with
oral feeling poopy Justin is because in
my opinion the pulse is a skill is a
more of a skill weapon than the auto you
don't just hold a button now right so I
don't mind that autos are in a place to
do so I'm just gonna make this
generalised statement
the conclusion is is it perfect no
there's always room for improvement
we know scouts clear but for the most
part this is the first Destiny meta that
when I play I'm getting killed by a
bunch of different things that's read
normally is like ah goddamn shotgun with
the felt winces lie ah you don't say
here come the fawn you always used to
get mad at one weapon but even last meta
we like our graviton Lance vigilance
right so for me I would have to say that
this is the first better that I can say
six names 68 names of dominant weapons
that I've been killed by consistently
but I'm happy I am happy with that bad
so I want to throw this to you I know
he's a little little oven talking laughs
ton of babies cuz I'm winning maybe I'm
too happy
maybe I got God roles and I'm living
through rose-colored glasses so what do
you dig II honestly I mean I think if
things are in a pretty good spot from
what I play with I feel like there's
options I know the things that I love
using generally my go figure on PC of
things a laser beam gun right side are
wrong pretty much a similar option
people keep telling me it's like your
right side it's probably even more
stable so I mean pulses for me feel
pretty good hand cannons are also viable
like ace has just been aces lethal when
you get those rounds in there man it's
throw dad even talking about other hand
cannons Trust trust us a shout out the
king of the chat Hall restore he said
he's running in there you know I'm
saying like Justin were who says drink
look at all these different names we're
saying I can't recall that in the
history of any crucible manner no I
would say you have probably
more options depending on play styles
now God roles will determine what you
can probably use I'm not gonna go pick
up like a cannon try it but like a
better Devils I can still I'm not gonna
probably get like a 2.0 or anything like
that but I can still probably hit my
average you have to take like a decent
better devils and then like shotguns
like I got a retold tail that is no it's
got a threat detector rampage and I got
a little choke on it with range master
work pretty solid I'm like that ones I'm
getting a couple shots with that one but
honestly go check out fallouts video yet
it's ridiculous blue bother a ssin a
second we're like postmaster and I had
one of those and I tried that thing that
sucker is broken like weirdly busted in
a way you're like why is this blue
shotgun in his his videos the same way
that's as though his video was called
like I hate shotguns because he's like I
have no idea because he compared it to
the toil in trouble with like an
identical role yeah I don't know why
this is winning
yes you know what so it was like
moderation that blue shotgun I'm like
okay so I actually had one of those used
it knows like yep that thing is kind of
weird it works better than you ever
expected would escalation from shotgun I
can think I we stole some shotguns in
here we got that we got on our perfect
paradox I'll use that it's been great um
I got this gambit one right now parcel
of Stardust like it's competing it feels
great provided you get a solid roll a
mid to say you never have a god roll you
know I'm saying you like King said you
could be out here winning and I can't
require really thought because I'm like
you I am having a lot of I can play
crucible this much since d1 and up bro I
got to let me tell you real quick I got
this clause of the wolf
it's a 540 pulse or p.m. pose kill clip
outlaw
the only weakness I would say too
because it's a laser it reminds me a
vintage nerwin mercy revered over the
mercy all right that it shoots so fast
and if you get that you just melt
ten peak time that kills crazy so I do a
little counterbalance stock on that bad
boy you don't say just to Connie you
know bring the kick down with critical
but here ba duration is late yeah it
could your thing no doubt and it's like
I do that I've been running outside it's
my first time taking escalation out of
the energy slot and cuz cause wolf is
energy so then that's when I've been
messing with paradox I've been messing
with possible and start us then even my
my I've been messing with Connor I got
the Connelly catalyst popping right now
so I've been being cheap with caller
[ __ ] you little cheap kills I got oh I
got a crazy bill right now shot the as
the crowd but give y'all secret right
now all the wall oxidant let me get your
shadow you've run void before they nerf
it because we meant nerf may come runnin
over war get them to get them kills
right you run nothing lasts forever no I
I hear people popping the money is that
dude still yes like it's still going I'm
like I don't understand so long I gotta
confess like I hope they leave it alone
it was because you hug has got blade
barrage it has BC too but this has got
to be the longest repelling dead and you
know when a void and you guess a warp
gets a kill he's get his house back you
know that we're done the dark matter /
so yeah it's crazy and you do that they
did charge one Oh see that's a big blast
radius - because I'll be like comes
around corners I'm like I'm behind a
wall man we do that I'm doing that
here's the bill now if you really want
to be cheap
you don't tell estou and energy right
don't tell Esther what first of all it
all revolves around Nasir X in sorry nas
wreck same as your exotic helmet void
kills any type of boy kills weapon kills
or ability kills increased super
regeneration right thrown Superman's on
if you have them it's not really
necessary because you're gonna get two
or three supers a match right then you
get either till if you want to be cheap
you get Telesto in the energy slot or
any of your favorite god rolled god what
Kollek weapons and just make sure your
heavy if possible is also void so any
void weapon kill supers going up
any void ability kill rubies going up
super mods soup is going up you see it
I'm saying like non-stop like I'm
getting 20 pieces 30 pieces it's crazy
it's crazy later kid catch you bet
thanks for jumping it moto yeah do that
I've been having so much fun I've been
messing around with builds and yeah so
I'll just that that was pretty much it I
know ramble but I just want to say like
I know we don't give them a lot of care
we always complain about what needs to
be fixing yeah things need to be fixed
Scout needs to be maybe a little bit
autos a little bit maybe you know I say
I'm okay with all those to be honest but
I would say Scouts
I think Scouts in my opinion Jaffa Li
nice and love may be those swords net
number two you know as far as what's
next and fix are the need I missed the
exotics because they had different
purposes that could have you could have
a little more fun with them the power
with them in PvE like the rain I mean
you have your dark Talon which I I've
been killed in and like one match and
all of a sudden like oh my god
somebody's using that weapon and is like
it can't get used but most of the times
swords and that's why they struggle in
pde right now is because they're still
just met smack smack smack like uppercut
but so many things when you're close to
them are gonna be painful like IRA smack
or a blaster justice like ground smash
swords they would well I think we'll get
to something where they're gonna be
looked at but it was just like swords
for me I don't know the ones who run
them in PvP like more power to you
because like they can just work me
sometimes but generally swords need some
help
I'd say autos need a little buff yes and
then Scouts you're 50% buff was only in
PvE and I'm where you needed that
invaded as well yeah well it's like just
it's what pulses can do and none of the
maps are built to be too long you have
your one whatever the new version of
what is it convergence or covetous yeah
whatever that version is I mean that's
got some longer lines but also I'd
rather use a sniper at that point Scouts
are just kind of a weird spot like yeah
I can't quite figure out what's what
supposed to because pulses
I'm gonna hit somebody with a sniper but
I also tagged him with my go figure just
about as well and that's the point where
I'm like I'm struggling to find a reason
to use this couch how do we feel about
snipers how to use uh they still flinch
like a mother yeah yeah like I'll I'll
get them I mean there's points were like
that map for example the the old
Pantheon person I can tag people with
them definitely put the little uh put
the little hat on top with the might on
my dreaded some heads off I mean my
turret adventure feels pretty good I
don't know why specifically that one
tends to be my go-to if I'm gonna go PvP
sniping so I don't mind that one and
I've definitely got picked off a lot so
I mean some people are capable but it's
like in it and I can't totally fight it
like if your aim down sights and you get
tagged you should flinch like because it
really pisses you off when you're on the
other side you see that scope you shoot
them and they're still able to hit you
I'm like I'm sorry I just hate your
shoulder you're shooting with a sniper
rifle you're no longer accurate so I'm
like I can't fault it too much yeah I
can get the drop on you I should win
right yeah I shouldn't since either pull
off pull back lose weight to another
lane because I mean snipers for me are
not one that you should be like quick
scope and turn around 180 no scopes like
that stuff to me does not feel like a
sniper purpose it never has now people
are skilled enough to do that more power
to you by all means I'm not gonna argue
but it's just how I don't feel snipers
should be but it's like there's some I
feel pretty like they feel decent but I
still feel like they could be better but
like the quick scopes and things like
that I mean that's just a talent I've
never had so I mean I'm not Brass but in
general the way a sniper rifle is meant
to work that's not kinda how I feel it's
supposed to work and I'm making a crap
for that cuz that's just not my thing
but what a shout-out your chair right
there you boy like it's going in
nobody's down you get a team by easy I
can't lie he a liar like Lester oh my
god he said that that and a shout-out to
Oscar he's like that dude over these
fixed that big can run for a week killed
halfway across the map gets bond on like
another point here he comes along son of
a I'll even be using my retold tail
which is void smashing doesn't matter
doesn't even do it and thing
because I'm just like just like throw
rice it I don't it doesn't do anything I
the Crisco he's like try try to blade
wash me and see where half listen up oh
you're talking about the arc deflect oh
yeah I was even heard like miss thousand
watts who's at one point she talked
about that and she was just saying she
was having a lot of fun just making
people angry just feel like yep oh yeah
just what that reflection or just having
a lot of fun be like well it was like
her new baby for a little while she's
just like toy and everybody would that
be like oh no that's me and it's just
like yeah you're just gonna die right
back so yeah if you can actually be a
moment it's hard to play brush could it
is it is typically so fast yeah like I
said watch super strong fast you have to
have up like you have to be in super to
have a chance to defend even with that
one you can't like hear the blade brush
now is pop your super and get your like
reflection up you're gonna be dead
before it happens so I was like play
browsers like like you know so it's it's
quick I mean but as we're talking
there's a lot of size as you said and
that's why I think it's not a completely
crazy statement you're like how it's
gonna be all controversial I think
people may have favourites of times but
honestly the options we were all talking
about
I think agrees to that point that you're
saying it isn't a pretty good spot yeah
I said I just can't remember looking at
my entire you know everything that's
equipped I got running out there and I'm
like you know a lot of these things vibe
all right every slide I've got at least
two to three weapons whether it be
kinetic energy even you know in the arm
heavy and um I just couldn't think I
really challenged myself I was like you
know when has it and it's usually oh the
problem with destiny and it's a it's a
very hard game to balance right check
out the Wisniewski nose to the sandbox
team we give them crap and stuff like
that but this game has so many variables
space magic and all those other stuff
you know I mean so to balance destiny I
it probably would never be an eSport
right it's just so many things that it
kind of could be out of whack you'd have
to do just like you would have to have
set loadout
I'm not even set load outs but just up
like here are three guns for your
kinetic here three this here three and
you can pick from those and you can
builds from there but like you would
have to kind of make everything in a
level playing field before you can't
really try that yes so that's why you
have one you just on the last two cannot
be doing it which is with the armor sets
now really tweaking towards Bill when
you have in like a shotgun scavenger
effusion scavenger getting more for your
Telesto or more for that shotgun
whatever it is you like per brick pickup
right those things make a difference man
when you have that you know reload a
perk like I actually um you know as a
war like I use um what was the snake
Fang arms why am i blanking right now to
help you reload fast typer totemic
listen uh why am i blanking on the name
that's the name of the part i forget the
name of the arms right now whatever
y'all know what I'm talking about
they're real old audience Ophidian
aspects oh yeah right so like that would
be a mainstay but because of different
perks and different armor sets you know
you can have something that reloads just
you know a shotgun or whatever you want
so now you're getting into the minutiae
of bills and it's just fun I'm really
having a lot of fun and likes all I got
left is you know really complain to
Scouts and that's what I got man have
fun the crucible try it
yeah it's like I mean some people give a
crap as a hello destiny crucible and
some people go to college or in college
it isn't a decent spot I haven't played
the multiplayer that much actually
because honestly I do enjoy the sneakers
well I like the the variety this makes
magic and all that stuff gives it a new
here hammers popping you like oh I
hadn't there was a guy who walked around
with the the new big hammer just wrecked
like my whole team everyone I'm always
usually playing with randoms and stuff
but I was like hey I was like he playing
that right spot and just was walking on
just working everybody with that thing
just to see even that thing have some
use of places of just I was impressed on
me yeah it's it curves towards enemies
to when you smash the ground that like
line turns yes in front you even move
it's gonna shift and still smash
underneath ass yeah it'll get you more
than you think you will and if people
are on a point may as well kiss that
goodbye so liking them with you man the
only next up I do feel like
Piper's and scouts should be next up in
line scout scout should be first
I agree but they did not like the DEF
definitely Scouts there's no doubt but
uh yeah man let's get it to this table
you know got we got going on so if you
guys have been playing a haunted forest
is still out there make sure at least do
the weekly bounding for seven master
work course you've got the 600 horror
story now if you're like high light
level I can see that being less of an
incentive just because like if I'm 600
I'm like do I really need an origin
story but it's got a decent roll on it's
probably not gonna be a game-changers
Crisco but it just said that earlier
but if you're like mid-level and it's it
is something you can grind out for it
definitely will help your light level a
ton so you have not granted out for
origin story horror story I should say
pick it up I mean it's an easy thing to
do it's fun you can do with randoms
might take you like ten or twelve or on
something like that and you'll probably
get it so really not too bad that gets
who just takes a little time and
honestly I kind of enjoy the variation
in there
I've got masks and I like what they did
with the masks I think we probably
mentioned it before but you can level
them up right as you use it more of the
perks like it unlocks more perks and
things like that and I think that'd be a
nice thing to see on some other specific
gear say there's like I mean somebody I
don't know if it was a comment somebody
said it I could have been even just like
Bethany read it like blind well needs
something to grind for out of it because
it's kind of a I agree it needs either
escalation protocol armor specific
weapons things like that
completely agree because blind well
whether just for the bounty is literally
the only reason we're all in there at
this point it's not doing as much
because there's not there's not that
instead there's not that like weekly if
you if there was something like a weapon
that dropped out I agree
what is it the tier 4 you know I'm
talking about the heroic version oh yeah
I know yeah if there was one that
dropped off like one of those three guys
every week to chanted for crying forward
that's the meatball or the big over or
the James like whatever it is if there's
a specific incentives ahead in there
more it's just more variety and even
something with random roles I mean
that's incentive right there just keep
going for it mmm that would be kind of a
way to get to it
so that's why for me blind oil has been
losing its luster in haunted forest was
I haven't gone back in there bro I gotta
be honest I got a confession of I was
saying man had his talk with the claim
not been interested in doing dreaming
city stuff I don't know why I don't know
why I just don't I guess a lot of it
revolves around that that I've just the
space is beautiful it's just I don't
want to do less it's a raid I'll do the
raid no well like you say like once once
I got my seeds of light remember that
was the reason to go in there mm-hmm any
I think you know there's like back in me
a khaki I'm just having fun doing other
things I guess that's a good thing
what do you think I mean are you still
going into the dream city consistently I
mean will you do it shattered thrown so
that makes sense right yeah I mean
that'll do when it's up that for a
hundred percent is for sure but it's not
up are you in the other moles are you
doing petra's brownies all the time I'll
do because it's an easy way to get a
high piece of gear especially I'm
looking for 600 varieties
I mean her just I mean even if it's like
knock out your dailies I'll pick the
ones that are quick like hey do some
patrols if it's public events I'll throw
it in there and if I see him I'll do him
but I won't like seek him out if it's
like go to a loss sector you know those
are quick so I mean some of the week
like the dailies and knockout you're
eight that's easy to do like just a few
a day even I mean as for blind well I
did actually MIT that was like last week
it straight up fell off and I probably
had been doing it every week just
because blind is a good thing for me to
grind for can it get up too and then is
it blind where you get the purification
or tool and stuff like that for you yeah
yeah cuz I mean I've been doing those
because I won't eventually have those
transcendent blessings if I do want to
go even more efficient right and those
transcendent blessings are gonna help
things like shattered thrown stuff oh
yeah so I mean there are benefits to it
but just those blessings especially once
you have those if you have that good set
of dreaming city armor or anything like
that it's it's gonna start losing its
appeal quicker right and it kind of
already has it's like it serves a
purpose but it's like
it it doesn't have the same fun factor
because it is it doesn't let repetitive
side and there's me kind of losing its
losing its shine and if they were just a
little bit extra in there it'd be great
yeah man shouts Coleman okay he's been
doing bounties in the diamond city to
hopefully get better roles on certain
guns an exotic he actually said that
he's not doing they don't really care
about the already story because he's got
a tiger's biting with Auto outlawed
killed close like a beast I feel about
it
alright so Oscar hit me he says just
real quick respond Oscar too bad you
like to list I have not yet yeah I mean
you know back on that discussion real
quick um yeah tell us was beast
it really is it's really good and I
think something was like and also
setting it like at LSO can beat a scout
but to the to your chats far as D I'm
curious like what do you guys feel on e
boxes chat you know the Dreaming city
the blind well like you guys in there
consistently you guys doing your Petra
bounties I'm very curious oh I just want
to know if this was just a me thing yeah
we'll see what they say I was like I
don't I mean it's just the dreaming
scene is cool I love running around in
there it's like the secret stuff when
you go on a TV set I mean I do these
Senate challenges every week that's easy
mm-hmm you do those um not really like
easy thing powerful gear like takes you
you know maybe 15 20 minutes knock it
out you can do it solo like be asleep
what happens to me I was like so that's
probably one of the easiest things to do
though and that's why I would say like
if you don't do much in the Dreaming
city it's 20 minutes for a piece of
powerful gear guaranteed you're done and
it's not that hard yeah I play was do it
first - I think I know what the problem
is here's the problem the reset comes
the whole map is littered up with gold
things to do right
I love crucible so I go in there first
then I'm like okay I'll do the
flashpoint
hit hit the flashpoint then I'll do you
know the three strikes you get the knife
all done then I'm like yeah
and gamete matches take a while they you
man if you get in a tude like if it ends
up going to the 3rd and you're like it's
like a 30 minute round this is 30 minute
run so now I'm doing for gambit matches
most likely because you do 2 or 3 you
get your powerful gear but then you
probably grab some trickster bounties
and you're almost close to finishing all
right let me play another one just to
finish this out whatever the kind of
thing now that's like 2 days we'll be
playing right Hey so they'll be like
okay what else I got left and it's just
always something going on and I just for
whatever reason I guess what I probably
need to do I think I know what it is
because I was told when you're doing
your light level chase you do dreaming
city lasts so that young yeah right and
I think what happens is I'm doing
everything else and by the time I get to
the weekend dudes wanna raid dudes want
to do other things and then I'm just
never completely dreaming city stuff
yeah I mean I could see that honestly
cuz like that would be generally the way
I'd want to do it is use all those lower
ones will I say like tier 1 levels
whatever just your flash points here
strikes and all that stuff to get you
know fill the gaps kind of work on boot
building up that light level a little
bit mm-hmm yeah go get the dreaming city
to get that bigger jump because I mean
that was the same thing I was doing when
I was leveling up I'm at this point now
those have less appeal because to me
once you get to I mean when you're in
the 5 90s you're like or if you're close
to almost 600 like it honestly doesn't
matter where I go so then I can just
kind of pick so I mean what level are
you you know like yeah definitely 590
yeah so I mean at this point they're all
gonna give you like small chunks so
literally just go pick whatever you want
it's all gonna drop about the same
because that's what I say to myself am i
I'm just gonna do the stuff but I have
fun do enjoy this any challenges though
like I think all those were all made
more of them there's there's six and
I've seen them all now and I was like I
wish they were like phew we hadn't seen
yet so yeah I mean like I think all
sorted say like and he's doing the
petrol bound is for easy gear blind well
not at all like blind well and that's
the thing as you need more people in
there I mean out
of like random people who can solo those
things you need people in there if they
don't understand some of the mechanics
later on it's one of those that's and
even for me I've thought about like
doing an instructor just like a basics
video on blind wall just for some people
to walk in and don't know what to shoot
or what the app themas are or the
plagues stuff like that but it's like if
people don't understand the heroic
version they don't even know how to drop
the shield mm-hmm yeah they don't yep
it's like when you get to trying to do
some of the higher ones now people are
probably higher light levels they could
probably eventually just smash their way
through it because more people are gonna
be up there but I mean blind ball is one
of those that I still have people ask me
like hey howdy hurts your subclass and
it's like I sometimes forget like the
pace that everybody plays that not
everybody and I've I haven't even rated
and I'm basically like on my two
characters like 595 600 what I mean I'm
not 600 but I'm like 595 on both if not
more mm-hm and I was like and I've done
a pretty consistent grind haven't rated
much if pretty much about one time but
then I forget there's some people being
like hey what level can you do this and
stuff like that and I went through one a
sentient child is like hey I'm gonna
lower myself down to like 550 and I have
people saying hey thank you because
that's like that's me or I'm a little
lower and I'm going I was doing this is
kind of like a trial just to show this
might be a recommended piece or the
difference in damage right people aren't
there yet so I mean yeah it's gonna
that's the part of the issue of not
having that incentive in blind well is
gonna be the people who need the help
are going to start having people wander
off in other games wander off on other
things and not have incentive when they
do play to go play in there and help the
people who need it the most
mmhmm yeah I'd be uh I don't know and
then for me you said you always go to do
your strikes I'm like unless it's a
heavyweight day those are not high on my
list see I like the strikes
I don't like um the story yeah I hate
the story missions or those are like
bottom of the barrel for me so petrol
bounties I will go back I'll go dude
blind wall probably over the story
missions yeah I don't like another ring
is like I just want it I like - I miss
the old d1 days where you just go on a
strike or whatever and it just keeps
going no just keep going just keep going
just keep going into orbit going back in
and it's like you got to pick it then
you stop you know I'm saying that it's
like the same
one out of like a same curated list it's
like I'm not I'm not feeling to be
honest I'm not feeling doing those
strikes though these are three story
missions to be honest I think they need
to did change the structure of it in
some fashion to make it a little bit
more appealing I like that the story
missions are there I just don't like
that it's only a couple let's just
randomize it why don't they just put it
like strike like put in a queue and just
let me rock yeah you know modifiers are
decent in there and stuff like that
because I mean sometimes you just wanted
to blast the room but it's like we have
played the story like I've done
PlayStation 3 characters I've done PC
I've gone through it on multiple
characters I've seen these things
multiple times so I mean they're if they
want to do the heroics like the stuff
they did for the general results of the
changes to those even if they were just
more minor tweaks like crank him up to
make him really heroic because honestly
they're really not hard they're not that
hard and if you want to give me
something to work through give me like a
norm give me whatever your current level
is and go give me like a nightfall level
of that thing that's gonna absolutely
what my but and just make make it a
challenge but make it have something in
there because they got a just the
powerful gear as people and that's what
some people have been saying why I was
thinking about doing Red Dead it's like
as they get closer and closer to 600
power level there's less let's have
incentive to do that other stuff mm-hmm
so no no that's one of those pieces
where yeah story story missions need a
tweak strikes from me or lower the
nightfall is still a challenge because
like you've got the scoring you've got
stuff like that why that stuff is not in
there like strike exclusive loot and
scoring why that isn't in the strikes at
all the normal strikes yeah odds me we
need more strike specifically those are
those old they bring the skeleton keys
back add more into the pool that you can
only get there and now to make that more
fun - sorry rambling I know we going
yeah but yeah so first of all lost as we
said going on they have a costume
contest going on so if you've got a
specific mask if you've got a set of
armor if you want to put your little
pieces all together with certain shaders
you do that go to wherever you
take a picture and submit it to bungy
Instagram Twitter whatever is and just
use the hashtag festival of costumes and
they're gonna pick their top ten so
that's kind of cool I mean it's just
like a it's just like throwing something
out there have fun find a goofy picture
people get creative with these things
someone is like curious what people do
like love a dance take a take a screen
shot you'll be on top of like somebody's
head or I don't know what somebody's
gonna like if somebody can do like a
dance on top of the invincible Knights
head and catch like the perfect screen
frame or something that's good one of
those you're like damn like to see some
of those it's just it's a random little
contest but those are always fun they
say group shots are welcome humor and
courage put on a mask and go to the bad
guys they can't keep us down so I think
they've had I think overall this is
definitely gonna be the best festival
without a doubt I would I'll quit out of
town yeah I mean just like the haunted
forest is cool the masks that you can
level them up is kind of fun they'll
give you more incentive so overall I
think it's been treated pretty well
mm-hmm but yeah next week so we got
quality life we got patch no we both
been talking a little bit what you want
to start this one out sir get us a
high-rolling now we talk about the Qod
leave we're gonna live our best qol
that's what we want to talk about now
yep let me get everybody so we can all
see it yes sir so yeah looks like we get
some basic changes 2.05 looking forward
to this one to general start off with a
banshee you'll give up to 25 gun with
guns with materials at a time so that
level up and go a little faster I gotta
say something here I have 6,000 gunsmith
materials I need something to do with
those before I like just start deleting
them I mean I need some cuz I'm not just
gonna drop sixth out cuz what would that
be 60 weapons just for rhenium vs rolls
yeah there needs to be some reason just
somewhere in 6,000 gunsmith materials I
need to get in a few minutes somewhere
in there it's got to be an ivory with
the black armory rumors yeah
you may good thing you may hold on to
those we I'm hearing things have you
heard those things but I've hear a big
piece of it but yeah yeah man so hold on
to that we may have some other vendors
we may need to give those to so you
never know you know say we got that we
got increasing stack size of grows ghost
fragments from 10 to 20 I like that it's
good let me let me hold on to more okay
all right side note here core
like big gave us 100,000 glimmer but I'm
still sitting at that cap why can't it
be like 200 300 it's like it's not and
if you play like for six hours and you
have a buttload then you spend it all on
something why is that a factor why is it
only ten why can't it be like 50 ghost
fragments mm-hmm like I always wonder
why these limitations on pieces when I
read like little like I can only have
five you know tear like tier three
charges now I don't seem to run out of
those they fix their drop rate versus
what was the place in the dread on those
you I would literally run out like I
don't seem to run out of whatever like
Tier three charge or whatever I'm
playing I get running back so I mean
that's fine but I mean ghost fragments
and stuff is they're gonna be doing a
lot of bounties if I if there's a point
where I stock a lot of them up and then
I come in for a week and just clear out
the bounties it's just one of those for
me I wish there was just a little more
space on a couple things and I never
understand where the memory space is
like to me like ghost fragments that's
got to be like a tick in a database to
me in my head I'm not a pro I'm not a
developer I don't know I don't even
think this is a database issue I think
this is Bungie trying to slow down slow
down hoarding this I don't think this is
database issue at all I think that
they're making
I think the Banshee decision was that
they knew coming in that a lot of
there's gonna be a lot of people like
you from D to launch to Osiris and war
mine that's gonna come in and cash out
right so they were like let's up the
rain you know that kind of thing that
screws over and like 90 percent of the
player base okay but that's good that's
part of a problem though I'm not saying
they don't care but that's the whole
whole inflation on the master records is
like just busted to a point of like he's
a vicious but so I think of the mind say
if you're a dev right they're whole
thing to me the theme of forsaking from
a development standpoint is to throttle
you to slow you down
no like they did that enough with the
way the light levels go like the soft
that type of stuff is the fact that like
stacks of things you're not gonna you
don't you can't level up with that mmm
cuz those things after a certain while
they're not even helping your light
levels so your stacks and stacks of 700
IO tokens isn't gonna do a damn thing
that's why I was like they made that
throttle specifically and they did
enough to make it I mean they slowed you
down
they didn't dad right so that's like
making these little stacks or little
little things here these are not pieces
to me that change the throttle in any
way there's just more of a frustration
that's not useful I think I think I
agree I agree I think what it is also it
comes down to your main issue which I
think you've made a fantastic point last
flashpoint which is the loop pool is not
as expansive enough yes right so if the
loop pool was expensive and you were
getting completely different things and
I think someone said this already and I
think this is a fantastic there's a
little tangent um idea is that we've got
all these armor sets and weapons in d2
year 1 that are just not being can't be
used you know I'm not gonna be used
because they don't have the new slots
and all that so why not just repurpose
them bring them back
you see I'm saying huh this so I have
all sets in there that I'm like damn
like I wish you know I got the same
thing weapons and stuff like that like
I'm really gonna gonna go back and use
this Scout I even have a trouble using
midnight cuz I'm like alright yeah it's
a good roll but I'm like I can never get
a model on it I can never get it you
know say like Cougars just like the best
roll you're gonna ask for so I mean it's
still that things still it's it's like
it's the one let's just let's just say
it'll never be if you happen to get a
rampage out well I should say you happen
to you know saying it'll never be the
Forsaken version
because you can't mod it exactly that
that's what I'm saying so I get it I
guess I think that's I think back to
your whole point about the gun materials
and stuff like that
if the loopholes expanded we weren't
getting thirty five thousand edge
transits and all those other stuff you
know that would make that throttling
seem less worse than what it is if you
know what I mean yeah if they're just
like a little more variety if they take
in and not even all of do you one year
all of your one you could do like some
select ones like bring back a few like I
can't even remember the gunman and the
mini hat and like start throttled like
with festival you could be like hey
that's some stuff back in or I mean
black armor it's gonna bring some which
will be good and I think it'll be well
needed but just to trickle a few of
those back in and be cool if like hey
here's the new reset occasionally you
might see some new stuff from you know
your gun Smith or from just random drops
in places other stuff might just
randomly start popping in people like
hey this is new like it's kind of a fun
thing to just you know whenever they do
a maintenance patch or something just
update the servers with a couple more
and just have somebody slowly trickle
and stuff in there just to give us more
variety cuz I'm not gonna go spin mm
gunsmith materials on like the same six
weapons like I was like getting
duplicates good point
so we got that and then uh yeah men are
reduced shader dismantle time from one
second to 0.25 can't get fast enough
here's the fun now you get to the [ __ ]
exotic duplicate waiting so when you
receive an exotic we're taking account
all the exotics you found and weight
them against exotics you have yet to
acquire this lowers the chance of
receiving exotics you already long
praise the Lord
right now look well man exotics that you
do not yet all will be individually
weighted much higher than duplicate
exotics when receiving duplicate exotics
you will more like less we're more
likely to earn armor pieces as they have
randomly roll perks an exotic quest
weapons okl malfeasance an ace of spades
are
remember it's jabiru are being removed
from the exotic Engram loop praise it's
the Lord's Day
they out here doing the Lord's work on
this 12 this what I'm talking about man
because as you know I mean you've had
the discussion in my opinion I've still
you say I have I say I have still not
gotten a forsaken exotic I did not count
Lord of wolves that so that's bounty
specific and tae-jun you wanted it
though man true true true no I cannot
tell all I got the gun at one but I'm
just not gonna count this one because I
just have to be I just have to be
mooring but I'm not gonna count this one
when I got that one you're like all that
was like that was my weight back and now
you got it you're like yes ad that's
like somewhat telling me yo this is
treasure map when this part of Texas in
this block it was did you do to get it
maybe to be honest I wasn't even doing
him a lot and I really started doing him
lady the last two weeks so once I
started focusing on really doing them I
got it quickly you know it's just
orangey in the wild oh my winters got I
get all of these all exotics and I'm
just like what is going I still haven't
gotten borealis as an Xbox guy you know
I'm still waiting on that but it's just
like hey I know you're faded in gram
once a week just by it be I should I
should that was the first thing I
literally like that's the first infinity
my bond done on a character where you
have the all the old armor yeah like
there's no question no III definitely I
definitely feel you on that so like did
these these this is just like man thank
God thank I shot the like it it's a yeah
yeah thank God I did these things needed
to happen now again from what they said
in the past is it gonna guarantee you
don't get what you've already had no no
but this is so important because it's
just it's it's sad I know people who are
in the same situation which is like they
haven't gotten one new Forsaken do what
are we in now like and I know it's crazy
because we wanted them
be rare but we like can we get something
that we've never had ever you know so
this is good to see what it would you to
thinking before you get into my hands
because I mean me I'm these are all like
logical changes yeah I mean they tweaked
it hard
they went from 1 to 11 on the rarity
so I'm like oh people exotics too much
huh like like trying to grind for stuff
like do you know Gjallarhorn things like
that the fixing of the class those were
brutally like RNG so I mean back in d1
this just reminds me of d1 more than yes
things are and now I just randomly must
have decent luck I was literally in the
middle of my night fall recording
yesterday for arms dealer and just in
that opening little section I was like
what oh I was like an exotic just popped
on the table what'd you get in it I got
in st. Louis Awards Wow and I was
literally recording of like sorry guys
don't be mad I just got one to pop on
video and a like crap
must be nice me and Jimbo we're on our
fifth factor Canon this is not helping
my cause with crazies I know a few
people like you the ditch is like it's a
it's like a normal days like raining for
everyone else bad weather it is a sunny
day for you know sad for me what I feel
like a reasonable amount drop like I've
had I've had what I feel like is a fair
day like yeah people are like it's
scarce they're in a drought there in the
depression like it's all bad times and
me I'm just like this feels like this
feels rare enough that I'm like oh sweet
I got one but it's not like holy crap it
only took me twenty ten thousand like
enemies to get one like I'm not to that
level and that's why I was like it's
just the difference I'd I don't know why
I mean it is orangey but apparently my
orangey roles are taking all of your art
engineer old oh it's funny celexa this
was huge definite like you said logical
that that needed to happen exuse with
the exotic duplicate waiting love it now
the next one big one enhancement cours
masterwork cause will be renamed
enhancement cause more sources will
award enhancement course they'll be
added to scrapper bound it's cool and
six up the spider weekly bounties nice
enhancement cause we'll be more visible
in the loop feed that's cool like all of
them exotic tuning there's some stuff
from wish ender increase base damage
which is good fix an issue with a broad
head perk would not probably activate
under certain circumstances which would
result in the loss of damage now that's
huge because that was one of the main
things I kind of held off from getting
it and I'm like I wanted to see it at
its most powerful now do you have you
have wish in there correct right I don't
actually I finish out her throne but I
have another question
oh okay gotcha see I started it I talked
to the statue I have to go what someone
get the thing kicked off my buddies and
I did that but then I didn't get a
chance to go finish it up because my
friends went out of town so I was trying
to do it with them and wait but yeah I
was like I got it started but no I
haven't finished it okay cool cool cool
and then we got a mouth three since
she's definitely getting some changes
and actually have you get it what say
you got about visas quest started no and
honestly I just haven't jumped into that
one because they didn't want in the loop
pool same way my chaperone hasn't been
picked up I literally have the chaperone
sitting at Amanda holiday and I just
keep it and escape because people I was
like even see another twitch people just
be like and yep still got that quest
thing on my screen because I don't want
it in the loop pool cuz that's like is
it once I've been just chillin like
everybody else on chaperone but for
malfeasance I want to kind of record it
in like progression and we'll get to a
good time for me to grab for it coming
up so yeah they increasing the explosive
shadow detonation damage that's cool
increasing damage against taken and
invaders which fits with the lore of the
weapon as well as gambit efficiency so I
like that big time and then we got a
trace rifles interesting anything trace
rifles would get touch so arm will spawn
with 50 ammo in the crucible very
interesting that's what they're out
right now I can I would say I remember
what the number is but I won't go too
fast
yeah I will say that I was yeah it
didn't have quite enough to leak I mean
you might miss like a little bit or two
so you need some time to kind of get
locked in and kind of let them go so I
think this feels like a decent number to
get like one maybe two kills but you're
not gonna get a lot because honestly it
burns to me I'm oh so fast so fast be
like still gone quick this is the same
problem why because I used to love load
of wolves in crucible and d1 and this is
the same reason why I don't like it
right now in d2 the ammo goes so fast oh
I'm like I can't they're gonna have to
treat you because I had to put it there
I love that gun but I like the new perk
but I just couldn't do it but trace
rifles this is interesting trying to
make them more playable in crucible they
also will benefit from the following
armor perks Auto rifle loader
unflinching Auto rifle aim autorad for
targeting precision weapon targeting
Auto rifle dexterity so anything auto
rifle related is going to be is going to
help and assist your trace rifle so
that's what they got man so overall with
the ohm you know there's a quality of
life stock patch 2.05 how are you
feeling about this stuff I mean this
stuff is all good in my opinion I don't
see much that's kind of a downfall here
I wish we had even another spot for
enhancement cores because I know they're
trying to give tangle sure a little bit
more use for those like wanted bounties
kind of give you more reason to do them
but it is gonna get really old to be
like gotta go grind another like 5 or 6
guys because some of those are like hey
run into a loss sector and go do that
but on the other side it's also hey I
don't want to run to this loss sector
again just to go kill this one guy I
mean they're on the scrapper bounties
which is I think that's actually kind of
cool because the scrappers are sometimes
like not always like the incentives not
there because they have 24 hours if you
pop in you're like you know it's not
that big a deal if I lose it now it's
like if that pops be like sweet reason
to kind of go and knock some of those
out I just wish there was like maybe one
more place or maybe good they they could
be random drops from doing this that or
the other thing just like just a couple
places where you might see them randomly
drop a little bit more frequently
because I still feel like while they're
there
unless you get like three or four if
it's like one master record for bounty
I'm still going to
be a little yeah it just I feel like as
limited as they are and as more people
want like I have an app master worked a
piece of armor like I don't have any
cash back yeah and that's like a piece
that we're all kind of waiting out on
just because I mean we knew this is
eventually getting here so we've been
waiting this long on this piece but also
it's like if there's a piece of Armand I
want to get it just a little bit higher
to have that resistance I don't feel
like it's worth the master record yet
and until they're a little more viable
it's just kind of I would agree I would
agree
um as far as that like I i'm not i'm
ready for weapons once i hit six i'm
ready to do this certain weapons I just
know where I'm at with them and that
this is the role for me so I will be
willing to do that investment you know
armor I'm with you I shout out to or say
oh my god it's so cool he's got a
question in the chat for you guys he
says what are you guys in your chest
what do you guys think about an exotic
quest once a week cruiser that give one
gives us 1/3 of coins that way there's a
guaranteed way to get an exotic once a
week I'll let you tack oh he's dead oh
no I'm here sorry I was letting you talk
no I might be okay with it like once or
twice but not a forever thing because I
think that takes away the if you always
have a very specific path to get them
you just know it'd be like alright let
me go do miser bounty then I'll get my
exotic for the weekend to me that takes
away the way the exotics are supposed to
feel now I know they're scarce for some
especially like I mean you vers me is a
completely different story right and
there needs to be some balance in
between there it sounds like that's
gonna be a little bit better but
generally I think if you give every
single one this like guaranteed way to
get it I think it's the way the feel of
them and that I don't want that d1 like
that's where they became too abundant
and therefore lit make their but they
don't want to lose their luster because
it's mmm some have their good some have
their bad they're not all amazing anyway
so then if you like just make him a
guaranteed yeah I just don't like that
it's just like another faded in Graham
but there's a fit pretty much it
and broke him anyway because you're
eventually gonna start checking them off
off the list yeah and and I've always
said you know quote me with words er
usage I feel he should be giving
bounties or something towards you know
enhancement cores now they're gonna be
called you know be the source like I
don't I mean I get it with spider yeah
but at the end of the day like they're
still gonna be useless there's still
nothing I'm really going him for so you
know and if they keep that pattern which
it'll be when black army come out then
that's what it seems like they're trying
to do like when black army comes out
then forsaken exotics will be available
probably yeah right I mean I don't surd
needs a different purpose I don't think
he should and I'm okay with like hey
play catch up on old exotics you can
still buy some old things there's
different rolls from him and that's for
older stuff but like that's a way for
people who haven't quite been able to
play can catch up on some of the older
things without being like oh my god it's
gonna take me forever you can jump on
the wagon of like older things from xur
but he should also like we have bounties
from every other place he should have
his own no reason he should miss he's a
limited time guy maybe it's just you
have the prismatic facet like that one
bounty you do for a challenge for him
yes hey and make it a challenge or
something be like hey go knock out a
nightfall what if it's your hundred K
nightfall mm-hmm like go find that
incentive to have people go like look
for a couple more people find that
challenge you got to work on find some
way to give him more purpose because
right now like I mean miser video does
well but I'm honestly shocked that it
does because I'm like really I don't
want her to break the exotic grind
because exotics should feel that way
that's literally the part that we were
talking back in February or March when
they're saying we feel exotics need to
be exotic and in my head my head
explodes cuz I'm going yeah no kidding
that was like I was trying not to curse
Flashpoint because I'm losing my mind
over exotics really to feel like exotic
and valuable and I'm like uh-huh yep yep
absolutely go look up the definition of
the word that's why it worries me that
it's just one of those pieces to where
like give him another purpose though but
don't just break the exotic pool so like
master work but like I'm sorry
enhancement core bounties would be a
great spot for him great fit would give
him a yeah man you know put a little
quest to some something they really got
to do something I'm very disappointed in
them with no mention of real sir tweaks
like they feel this is at a good place
like the I'm just like okay you know and
the only thing I can think is they like
I think what it is is this is this is an
example of Bungie I have my theory this
is an example of Bungie doing tough love
to the player base which is like oh yeah
exactly too easy huh oh yeah you get
into public events huh like that's like
now you get nothing now now you get all
the exotics Reserve that a drop raises
dries out like you don't learn like I
think it feels like it's like they've
been something yeah they're kind of
turned people into be like yeah this
stuff's actually gonna be hard to get
welcome to not year one of dusty to this
is what it should have been and they're
trying to steer people to get to realize
like this stuff is been to be hard to
get and honestly the harder it is to get
the better it feels when you do and
that's one of those things you can't
when you get that drop when you get that
rare thing to happen and I mean it
sounded like the meatball was insanely
rare I was like I got one and I got
lucky an absolute lucky but it's just
like it's just it's if you take away the
carrots on the stick we go back to that
casual don't really care about playing
anymore and that's what we want to avoid
and I always check myself when I
complain too much even for a second
exactly um that's that look you know if
I did get everything how invested would
I be if I got everything so fast there
was direct pass laurels
to direct exotics that you know how much
am I gonna cherish how much I'm gonna
want to continue to play so it's a tough
balance and I do get it you know at
least with
this job they've said though they're
going to address exotic duplication so
Tuesday is cannot get here fast enough
man yep mm-hmm
so what does she got in the cheetah claw
no I mean just like the little tweaks
and stuff and trace rifles malfeasance
getting to tweak wish under like just
incentive to go after those a little
more I think we'll be overall good and
just the exotic drops for I mean for the
other for like the 99.9% of people
besides me this will serve everyone just
everyone well because even if I do get a
drop and I get some arm or at least it's
a random roll so overall good stuff if
you haven't been playing about or if you
haven't been playing gambit get ready
assume so couple things one the big main
piece is the fact that the meatball is
going to be more frequent oh he will be
I'm sorry ascendant primeval if you want
to get technical
he's gonna be showing up a lot more so
the patch on the 30th on Tuesday is
going to be boosting his rate now
remember when you go through it's gonna
be the most prevalent of his spawn rate
on the highest taking cursed week but it
is still gonna be notice will be boosted
on the other - I said on the like the
highest tier 3 which will be like the
strongest taken curse is gonna be on
November 6 that week he's almost like an
even spawn with the other 4 or 5 so he's
gonna be like you know one at a 5 106
107 he's gonna be in there you play
enough you will start seeing him
scratching them next week he's gonna be
in that kind of middle range he's gonna
get a boost up from what he is so you'll
see him some but it's been you know
maybe like one out of 20 like not 1 out
of 1 million like it's gonna be better
but biggest thing everybody's working on
infamy those infamy resets gets you some
really really good rolls so if you
haven't been playing gambit gambit
should hopefully be flush full of people
playing week oh yeah me and triple
infamy during the week so from Tuesday
to Friday and then Friday reset wenzer
shows up triple infamy until Monday so
if you don't play that much during the
week even more beneficial on the weekend
but yeah triple infamy is gonna be huge
yeah that's gonna be huge that's a big
deal that's a big deal and I like these
vents man it's so cool it really got me
when they did this with crucible that
was the other thing I didn't mention in
other words why I had so much fun with
crucible
I'm just getting my glory poppin you
know I'm in towards you know reg Rick's
and stuff like that and um to see this
this is a unless I gotta be honest to me
how do you feel I feel like low-key
camping I like the best loop what do you
take good stuff in there
like I have one bygones and I did not
get a good one does I don't even know if
I kept it I may have broken it down I
gotta try and look now but I'm not
really happy with that role so I haven't
really tied around with that gun that
everybody seems to love and picked me
off and that thing is lethal the rocket
launcher because you can get I think
it's the second infamy reset I've it
seems like pretty consistent aside the
first or second reset that rocket
launcher with tracking and cluster bombs
like that's your rocket launcher that is
your void rocket launcher from that
point forward so I mean there's some
good stuff in there so like overall I
don't know if it's the best but it's got
some damn good like Dredd adventure it
just the way that sniper feels mm-hmm
feels good I don't know like it's
definitely they did well with that
loophole I don't know if I'd say that a
pest but I definitely say it's
definitely a solid loot pool I think for
me because I've gotten a lot of the
weapons I've gotten first of all has it
of the cast Oh sick water good old let
me tell you my role this is my only
hazard of the cast and this is why you
guys give me some crap about RNG it
doesn't all follow my way okay I go with
quick-draw and grave robber yeah that's
that's garbage
I like grave robber though what yeah
rifle Roboto [ __ ] is kind of wasted I
wouldn't quick draw on my primary sorry
the complete its trash come on just a
minute it's trash no average it sucks
straight-up awful rules I get though
like I'll be like Oh what did I get I
got a new dread adventure let me see
it's got hipfire what's the word wait
want you to crouch down is it feel I'm a
field properties light will feel
purposely reserved but it's also the
Crouch but it's like take it no it's got
a different me I know what you're
talking about somebody's getting that
one really like yeah taking me or
whatever is just like oh I'll be like
come on family like sometimes like these
certain times I get disgusted with Auto
loading holster is not a terrible perk
in theory with certain levels but it
just like it could have been something
else like if that's all I like you don't
have enough ammo most of the time for
that to be viable ever in PvP a because
you're not gonna worry about on your
primary because I mean you switch over
maybe if you switch back but generally
you're giving up basically every other
good perk over that and you don't have
enough ammo for that ever but to be a
good thing in PvP impeding it's not
really that big of a thing either I felt
like it had better weight or use or so
it felt better in King's fall when that
gas cocoon-like at it like cuz it was on
the machine gun it was on that sniper
and you'd hear it just go like and it
was just and that was it seemed to have
a better use and now it's just it kind
of sucks in my opinion - Oh real quick
Justin workman I have to give him credit
for this okay he said he's been getting
catalyst left and right I just got
borealis like month to D I think Loki
the catalyst drop rate got increased
busted bro I got vigilance I've got
vigilance wing
I've got County I just got huckleberry
yesterday
I will say do your huckleberry all clear
is nice I get on that oh yeah the with
the catalyst even better cuz you get the
full clip yeah huckleberry is nice I'm
working on that it just kills they just
want you to get kills with it activity
go down and I got woman what I really
want that a having gotten is war to
cliff because I'm a war cliff guy I like
that drop from cuz I think it's um just
like hard strikes or something like this
look cuz I mean that's one I definitely
enjoy using I got smashed with it the
other is coming around the corner I was
like and then I hear just the words like
it doesn't really matter where you jump
you're not really goodness if you're an
in the general area there's like a
comedian that's like if you're over here
now nothing is over here like the threat
is gone it's one of those for sure so
Kylie shoutout to catalyst they've been
they have actually that is very very
true I've kind of forgot that was it was
is one of those little stealth ones like
they don't say it you know they did it
cuz like I mean I was on that see that's
where me I had like a drought like
everybody's having issues in the scouts
and stuff like that it feels like I've
seen just everywhere even if I only got
like one or two it's like one or two
more than I've seen in like a month so
yeah it's been a bit more frequent but
yeah I got the borealis catalyst nice I
don't even know what it does yeah
and good morning Chronos like and shout
out to chat guys by the way both sides
blown it up today thank you guys um but
yeah so this is a final piece keep an
eye out once update to point 0.5 is live
ascendant primeval servitor spawn rates
will increase even though it's not full
curse week you might find yourself I
died with that evil meatball I love how
they actually mention people I love how
the community sometimes will throw stuff
out there and they just like take that
one little thing I this is actually
official and it's like thank you and
just good luck on your hunt for
malfeasance and that's why somebody
who's asking me it's like I'm gonna work
on that quest
next week of course I think there's some
grind pieces I got to see what's
involved but I kinda want to record it
and make it a whole piece just cuz I
think that'll be I don't know if there's
a mission and they're involved or
whatever so but yeah yeah but next week
take some time live in there it's that
second week of the curse nothing crazy
if you're not stuck in any other games
gambit and honestly spend some time in
there cuz that double and triple infamy
if you're going for those resets yeah
yeah that's gonna help you a lot yeah
can't be it's nice I really have fun
playing matches Malone but I do enjoy it
man I really have fun so I will
definitely be in there yeah I think
that's one of those things that's like I
know the matches go long but when you go
one-on-one especially if you get smoked
to the first match and then you come
back and kick their button around to
you're like okay now now we evened it up
like let's see what happens and it's
there's that intangible piece of when
you get down to that final final match
in if if you get smoked it's like it
kind of takes the wind out of the sails
but if it's close you're getting
invasions people are trading back and
forth it's that moment of that every
round when it's actually close is when
it's honestly it's at its absolute best
yes when it actually just gets when
people have the strategies to absolutely
destroy them I mean more power to the
coordination teamwork they like waiting
for the first invasion everybody to sit
in there and then you can go like you
know somebody does melting point
somebody does well of radiance and you
just absolutely vaporize that bus it's a
cool strategy but I wish that what I
wish it felt more organic in the way you
take him down and those really good
fights back and forth trading those are
the moments when gambit is at its
absolute best and those that's what that
game mode is supposed to feel like so I
know sometimes if you're playing a solos
and believe me I have had the solo
struggle going what are you guys doing
and then there's times I lose motes and
I'm like I'm sorry you guys I know you
don't know me I'm not this terrible
because you can't talk to anybody like
nobody's like other people it's a
different thing but those moments in
gambit where you actually get to feel
that like push and pull the tug of war
going oh that's when it's awesome I love
that that's cool mm-hm
but they have a new thing they've done
this before it's time to bring some
people into destiny to force they could
nice
refer-a-friend now back everybody on
this podcast I'm sure has this game but
if you have people who are on the fence
you have friends that were playing d2
they already fixed we just got to by
forsaken so that's an even better
selling point for you to your friends to
be like hey come on
40 bucks jump back in the games in a
good spot there's a lot of fun things to
grind camp it is cool em Indians it's
all those little pieces and now if you
do that gonna get some bonuses for both
you guys to get some nothing totally
unique but actually like how the shaders
are they're cool um so they say veterans
it's on you to show that referral the
ropes the quests and it's just another
quest to do which is always just
something fun and quest gives you ample
time to get your friend up to speed from
perk sets and loadouts kinda lets you
show them the ropes and then it also
lets your friend can it get to play with
somebody so this is a way to bring new
people in I actually kind of thought
about doing kind of a giveaway for
somebody and like walking him through
this something like that just you know
welcome new Guardian or something like
that so that might be a cool thing it
looks like we got some rewards that
we're gonna be able to get from it mmm
looks like we've got this ship looks
like there's this emblem in the
background kind of the linked Guardian
thing it's similar to what I think they
had before it was just like black before
and this one's orange now that looks
like borealis am i right yes we're
getting it maybe the shader itself or
maybe it's a different it does look like
borealis now I got the gun I'm trying to
go pull it up on mm-hmm it really does I
was like it has a very striking
resemblance cuz I've only used it a
little bit mm-hmm I gotta look up the
damn gun hold on
but the three ring around it just to see
yeah maybe a little different by the way
if you look if you google borealis you
get the Northern Lights heads up guys
yeah I mean that is that on definitely
borealis they've just put a shader on it
but I mean I like the longer you watch
this animation that color changes for a
while it's a thirty second animation so
it's just a cool piece of adding like a
literally an animated shader to it like
that's kind of Awesome there
not a lot of it I mean there's some that
kind of give different reflections but
for an animated shader that's actually
really really cool Chris gopis it's
definitely yeah borealis yeah so so
apparently I don't know if we're just
getting a shader a ship a little both so
yeah there's your emblem it looks like
there's what that bar is gonna look like
in 10 you can also get a sparrow Oh a
couple different pieces nothing crazy
but if you do have a friend you want to
bring into it it's an ornament Chronos
to say and it's an ornament for borealis
something like that because that could
be Aries and it's like all shiny but it
sure it's just an animated one ages cool
I like the animation even be asked
it is funny though if you ever see any
animations in this game like it's the
shell that I have that I love it's like
Star map 1 or something like that yeah
if you move your mouse around on screen
you can actually tell the ghost itself
is transparent and they actually put a
layer behind it and you're actually
moving the top layer over it and it's
not just an animation it's like slowly
moving it behind it and if you move the
top layer like your mouse to change
where the menu screen is that you
actually see through it blinded it's
kind of funny to see how they do some of
those things amen
but yeah set veterans who were for
multiple destiny to players will receive
additional rewards so it's just kind of
a way to bring people in I like it I
mean it's a it's a good time if they're
if you're if somebody's looking for
something to play and for 40 bucks
you're gonna get everything catch up or
60 bucks for pretty much everything
you're good to go it is a really good
value it said honestly the games in the
best play I mean usually I doesn't say
crucible is in one of the best place
that's been the whole game I mean it'd
be hard to say hey vanilla dusty one go
play curse of Osiris maybe skip that
part
outside of that like vanilla that
campaigns kind of cool then go use a
boost and then join us in forsaken that
alone is probably worth your money alone
just to have that full experience so I
think that would be cool veteran player
requirements just little pieces you had
to actually own forsaken yes
other than that patch is coming not
really too much downtime just their
usual no expected downtime that sounds
like there's going to be doing it on the
back end they just may kick you out of
your activities before ease that
he's back up and live that we do have a
couple yes she's here for just known
issues master work weapons sent to the
postmaster I did not even know about
this which is kind of scary I'm wonder
if I missed out on something I don't
yeah so we are investigate reports where
wardens law and other weapons can be
dropped master work but if the weapon
gets into the postmaster it becomes a
break that's uh oh
no no boy no no I mean it's one I don't
even know if you just caught it in the
side of the drop screen and then you go
to check you later
that would really tax off yeah you want
like something like if if you caught it
you'd be like what the what yeah play
bond thank God I had space because I got
a it was curated mmm no petra's weekly
challenge somewhere it's not actually
meeting the objectives or something for
one of the weekly bounties gotta throw
an emblem not actually counting the
completions Valerie that's not counting
which is really weird because that's
kind of for those quests it's a big deal
for me so yeah
effort even gifts Ryan put I don't even
know what that is yeah me neither is
that the effort is that like the boost
the character boost or something I don't
know I don't know I don't know whatever
it is I don't have I don't know who
we're actively check reports were ammo
finder this is a big one now somebody on
reddit I don't know the thread I'm sure
if you google heavy ammo finder and read
it you'll find it somebody went through
and did like 5,000 drops worth or
something like or kills or whatever it
was they went data testing this thing
and they figured out like almost having
heavy ammo finder on yes I saw this yeah
it's actually drop executive affect your
that I heard about that and I did catch
that on ready and I set up I will be
switching those perks up over my armor
cuz just one is enough if you put
anything more than one statistically the
way he did the math you know it actually
comes in some cases decrease the chances
so I was like yeah now I will say I feel
like you how much have you been playing
PvE um president which activity I've
been you know I mean just any in the
past like weaker
sure whatever since this little patch
happened no it's like forsaken like do
you okay what I'm asking is and I was
trying not to see like trying not to
like mm-hmm basically leave the question
understand me but wish without like I'm
a heavy I'm a painter for Erick sucide
but if I go heavy weight that crap is
everywhere like I feel like heavy ammo
boxes like stealth got a little buff -
yeah yeah I feel they drop a lot I feel
that if you have the right specially if
you have the right armor set and stuff
like that um yeah I definitely I
definitely feel that way there's been
times when I'm like am I so much I'm
gonna ground I want to shoot more heavy
you know to use it you know to be able
to pick stuff up off the ground so yeah
I would agree with that okay I was just
kind of wondering honestly cuz like I've
been playing through I was going through
night falls with heavy weight a couple
strikes and just some random activity as
I was doing I was like I'm seeing
noticeably more because I mean I kept
being frustrating to me like I could
like heavy Emma was a like any issue I
mean you're still a lot of orange bars
that weren't dropping majors weren't
doing it and it just wasn't seeming
there and not all activities but I would
say in PvE it feels like it kind of got
a stealth buff because it seems more
apparent to me no I have been playing
kind of curious what you guys think
about that as well I I experience it's
definitely been that that way okay cool
so I mean maybe they're making little
and that maybe they don't want to just
announce these tweaks cuz they never
announce that anything was wrong but I
think these are little things when they
you know they stealth buff catalyst a
little bit they stealth buff like the
heavy stuff they know things are there
and that's sometimes what it's like we
may say stuff now
chaos reach you know you're worried
aside but I know that one but it does
seem the bungees like they're there on
top of it more than anything and this
has kind of one big shadowed I was going
for it's like a little something waiting
on heavy almost like maybe they found
some little glitch or bug or we work and
finally it's like okay it's a little
more frequently it just things are the
more this whole forsaken thing goes
along things keep getting better
to me most of the most things have been
improving and improving and keep making
this thing just something that it's like
easier and easier to say yes play it yes
it's in a good spot and it's just and it
just keeps being an improvement so it's
one of those pieces that has been kind
of nice to watch yeah absolutely
what is Justin workman say I'd give
myself head trauma leading to amnesia to
learn destiny to with me
I would I would why would it be so bad
to learn destiny to with me is it too
much am i setting the bar high even
though it's not like I was like I don't
know or just do I talk too much which is
always you get to learn man you see here
you get to learn from the great artists
class is in session take break take
breaks of water you know they stay
hydrated up to shape exactly they'll get
the digest that all this media
information but as we go that's mostly
it they got a couple videos of the week
they soloed voor guess if you have not
seen it I did not even think of this by
the way the only reason I want to show
it no but they so love or get with Rat
King
really now the mainly reason they use it
is like click click like shoot shoot
shoot kill an enemy reload go invisible
and your mobility around that room just
to work the ads and not be visible to
shoot invisible shoot you shoot
invisible and they just like they take
out all the ads and then just as you
normally if you want to go that like
that kind of safer method then you take
out the Wizards and go work on your
damage but those ads like shoot shoot
shoot invisible that idea I was like
never even crossed my mind that was that
was a really cool use and it's why I
called it kill disappear repeat and I
was like that's that's damn creative
that's pretty cool so and then of course
just crazy raid stuff but they are the
community manages except probably Cosmo
and Dylan are out there
at twitchcon so out there joining the
party out in that world just if you're
out there you for whatever reason I just
want to go visit by they'll be meeting
some people so they're just out there
having some fun sounds like pretty good
times
um but yeah overall general table stuff
we got some basic week this week taking
Curtis week to last week
now last week is the big thing we've
just that quest coming up yes so the
murder mystery we've got some data mind
stuff that everybody thinks it's gonna
be master Ives I mean we know it's
master I've but actually digging into a
deeper working with holiday potential
heavy machine-gun exotic getting into it
date in mining that there's gonna be
some ornaments for it I mean people like
kind of ruin the surprises sometimes I
know they go in the data - go ahead
but want to get into one final topic for
you guys speculation of the future or
you you want to take this thing away cuz
I've been talking about I'll jump in
though I already checked 35 minutes this
but yeah we've got speculation data
mining out there about destiny three
it's in the works
potentially Christopher Barrett is game
lead which he's been kind of a live team
guy I like that he's gonna be main point
like main point man on it if that's true
they say Luke Smith has involved
somewhere up there of course I don't
think he's gonna get like an emotion but
he's he's involved but I think and again
I don't think anything he specifically
did was like hey we're going to miss
physically I had no like it a lot of
that stuff was decided by committee I
mean he had yes he had his face
plastered on it but I was like I mean he
was not the one making like the sole
decision I'm sure no true true that but
I mean I have to say um I say said
controversial his his arm muster I wanna
be very careful how I say this he lost
like remember when he started right
taking king was his claim to fame right
that was his baby and he was lauded and
rightfully so and then when d2
development came on he him and
Noseworthy were the leaves on d2 and we
all know
to launch so again I'm not gonna put
every single decision on him no but at
the same time I think it did stain him
I think D to launch did stay him and I
think the brass is moved on but Barry as
far as in I mean putting him in the lead
role because that's a decision for Luke
not to be the lead actually my eyebrow
right it's like interesting man I'm
saying so I don't know how you feel
about it I mean I say not everything is
on his shoulders but anyway you are the
one who eventually said like if you are
say Game Director if you're Steven
Spielberg your names on that movie you
made though a lot of those final calls
you gave approval you do have it's your
stamp on there while it was like while
there may have been group decisions it
is your stamp that is saying hey I'm
backing this 100% in my faces to the
media and there may be some that are out
of his control and things like that and
they wanted to go in a different place
but yeah I mean as you said it's like it
didn't sit well with the community and
that's been kind of a tough piece so I
think yeah you're gonna enjoy your fifth
better devils nope Lucas my guy yeah
they never leave never lived up to that
in that I remember the D to reveal
quote-unquote press conference like it
was yesterday and you know when they
came on stage and you know even um
what's the joint that we never used are
still broken guided games these things
I'm just like so my gut tell again this
is complete I know nothing I am guessing
right now right but if I had to guess
I'll take an educated guess on the state
of things when this game hit rock bottom
right mm-hmm was it Barrett spearheading
the change things around to give the
community what they want movement wasn't
he kind of thrust into things or am I
getting confused with um damage Who am I
kidding
is damage damage Barrett right which one
is Dan damage is Dylan commuting guy
right who's the one so really I know
they switch they when would have
different forgot that community guy that
damaged or whatever one Twitter yeah
it had to be involved right but I
started to see Barrett more active on
Twitter I think he was lead of the live
team if I remember he was like lead of
alive and definitely everything
basically like they kicked off d2 and
then you know Luke went to were I think
that was kind of like he did it he had
it out the door but then like from that
point forward whatever was live and
changing was on I think Chris repair it
was that guy I think could be totally
wrong of course yeah but like as you're
saying like he was the guy like involved
in like the updates in January and
February actually posting that stuff in
the 12 like getting those deep dives
like I think he was that guy after
little yes I agree I agree I think he I
think he had a in I found yes I fell he
had an integral part in D to turn around
right to get it out the mock the Myer
realized what people want he was part of
that crew and it almost felt now saying
Luke wasn't involved in any he who knows
he could have been behind the scenes
still helping out with this thing turned
but the vibe I got was no actually they
did say like he's working on d3 they
bummer they kind of inferred like he
wasn't going to be doing any more with
d2 so again you know I just read that
and I'm like okay interesting and I
don't have any problem with it you know
I'm saying it you know have a bit of the
old have a bit of the new you know
trying to keep this thing keep this
thing rolling
you know obviously we're getting to I
want to ask you the next question which
is more speculation you know obviously
when we think this thing's coming you
know and then obviously let's talk about
rumored settings and where this thing is
going so now no it not spoilers because
nothing's confirmed but yeah ain't on
the nine makes me wonder if that's just
a guy from Bungie because the nine cuz
ur is of the nine and it's anonymous
denying I'm like calm lines like was
that not a dude from Bungie mean like up
teaser I feel like is almost deej
that guy is so good at dodging questions
he knows exactly what to put out there
and being like oh well this is kinda
it's like they're almost doing that
tester feeler moment like a year before
so that's I was like that if that's not
a guy from bunchy he has hacked their
servers because they have got so much
they usually have a lot of things pretty
tight-lipped yeah for him to have that
level of detail has some he's like he
went in did maintenance on the AC and
also dropped a USB like drive so he can
get into Bungie servers cuz I don't know
how else he can get the informations
like he's doing like a Mission
Impossible hack
I don't yeah I don't know cuz it's so
detailed and it's usually so damn right
Oh yo accurate so second speculation do
you want to go location yeah man we're
talking you ropa yep so um we know we've
seen artwork from this thing for the
longest it's been speculated from many
dlcs for the longest of where you know
it's gonna be and um yeah man it talked
about that at that moon is so it's it
icy moon and they're talking about the
other thing I've heard is Guardians
using darkness yeah they're talking
Guardians using dark darkness which is
very interesting obviously we've been
hinting with stuff like this
you know Gul and people trying to get
the travelers light and obviously we
know since the goal since the ending of
you know there's main d2 story know that
on a foreshadowing where they've
actually said it admitted that that's
every planet is your sequence that you
see once the traveler has awoken there's
a sequence and where destiny is going
with each DLC moving forward you know so
yeah you know it's it's it's gonna be
very interesting with that they're also
talking about arm hinting at that fifth
race which is arm
we call them was it to space Doritos
that's what I've been calling them I
heard somebody others
I feel like Tiffany probably coined
Allen or I heard it on a stream but yeah
space Doritos the space debris those
there so we're gonna probably see what
you know that race is
you know obviously um there's this so
much man you know there's so much gonna
so we got that and then from my
understanding and I believe shout the
unknown player arm we started talking
about the the nine right that in that
race the Jovians call me if I'm wrong so
and I believe that's that's yeah so it's
like oh yes that's evil space Doritos
ominous darkness like yeah man so we got
that come we gotta find out what race is
that you know I mean who occupies that
but um yeah with the whole Europa and
apparently that's where the Jovian lived
that's the race of the nine you know we
make we finally may find out what the
hell is going on with the nine what's
this whole deal you know with them so it
there's a lot to unpack there's a lot of
time back here you know and then
obviously the final thing outside the
rumors will be speculation on release
and um you know we're talking possibly
you know 2020 that kind of a deal that's
or I could see it because this annual
pass heard there would be a second
annual pass like should probably some
expansion you've got on this in 2019
September kind of on that three-year
cycle so then it would be because he had
year one two and three and four so then
your dusty two would be four or five and
six cuz we're in five yeah we're think
some yeah within the fifth complete like
fifth year from so then after that
three-year cycle D three potentially
like going along with next-gen consoles
yes and I think your timing is perfect
if that if that follow soups and um
which also what I want to talk you also
including this was that perfect time to
set up cross progression man that cross
save at a minimum has passed out to be a
thing mm-hmm
I mean I would buy a copy on every
console straight up without a question
absolutely I have like full collections
on every song console to be like hey you
want to play you know hey you want to
play my brother
hey somebody on PlayStation who's a
follower I would switch over between all
of them in all
it would be really nice if I like hey my
go figure how does that feel on
PlayStation versus PC I could literally
switch over and try it
go figures amazing on console Oh like
some people like some people have
watched my videos though and just dude
like that thing is a laser and like they
just say on consulates not quite as
probably that is dining is yours
just a beam yeah I mean that rate
picking things off but I mean it's good
but it's like just even switch and be
like hey this feels better here like
stability on console is very different
and aim-assist versus PC like aim assist
and stability on PC is much less of a
factor like listening to be like that
stuff down so even that testing alone
would be fun but just to dude I want to
play with you like that's yeah that's
what's so much effort into a save and
this I was talking about could have been
Guardian radio or somebody who knows
what Dustin podcast I listen to because
this is not the only one ah mm-hmm it's
just the idea sorry if you guys hear
noise outside I it's all through
bungie.net and that's I think what they
were saying it's like it's all saved
their dim like destiny item and when I
go in I literally can click down to be
like okay PC ps4 like it's all sitting
in their destiny uh so if I log in maybe
it takes a second to like you know a
minute to transition over and be like oh
you last played on PC give us a second
okay hmm
that's fine what if it takes me another
minute to log in and be like hey do like
a little tick counter like one to 100%
be like transitioning or whatever to you
know different I don't if that's all it
takes and that I can sit there and play
on another console or play with
different people that would be great I
would love that
absolutely absolutely so um you know we
got that we've also got um obviously we
definitely the cross possession but we
also have its far so even more leaks
from an on in terms of what might be
happening within gameplay and he's
talking about open world PvP versus II
kind of dark zone areas you know a World
of Warcraft
shoot that unit as if us9 world did it
long before long before us console plebs
we don't know but like the way that
would work was actually well done in
world because you'd have some regions
you'd be leveling up through and you're
like okay this is basically going to be
like if you have good versus evil alien
language dark some areas is your
leveling up say you pledged to the light
okay you pledged through the light and
you're always there and there's some
safe zones when you're leveling up there
may be some zones of contention in a
like a mid-level and then you'll go off
and do some questing to level up in a
safe zone and then you'll come back to
like more of a higher level in gamma
Sharia with quests and stuff that you'll
be doing what yeah it's open open field
on you and enemies and everybody else
yeah kind of that concept is amazing in
thinking about they pull this off man I
mean this sounds it man shouts oh my boy
SWAT he had always this is one of his
like you know wishlist kind of things
for destiny in the future you know
imagine if they had that and I'm for him
to get this information I gotta tell it
I don't know what's going on he's gonna
go crazy so they look like they really
you know they wanted they want to still
keep the casuals in there but they
really doubling down kind of on RPG
elements trying to make it even more
hardcore even forsaken so that's the
other piece I saw is the more hardcore
RPG which is for me what they're leading
towards now and they just need to dive
deeper in and that's my opinion that's
kind of why I really wanted to ask you
coming from
Orla Warcraft and like you know even
division dope deeper than destiny yes as
they're getting into the random roles
they're getting into pieces more they're
finally getting a warlock to have like a
support bill yes those pieces are like
dribbles of a little bit that could be
like the full stream of like this is
gonna be we're going to that next level
and yeah do you is that a good thing for
you or not oh absolutely I mean this is
the key I just want to finish off cuz
you literally lead me into the next
point that a non-aligned set which is
that you know he's saying now I don't
we'll see more it's gonna be more
forsaken II I like the terminology right
and he says that we'll see more quests
kill trees perhaps more NPCs and then
his last thing was that um if they
really want to go all the way Ball Z
with the you know the whole RPG element
by the way absolutely they're gonna
really push down hard core elements and
really they said a lot of Guardians who
want to play just two hours a week will
abandon the game they're going all out
with this RPG stuff so when I hear that
I think now you know for the people who
love division you know for the people of
wild people you know if they really get
into builds and all this stuff and man
if they go back to the skill trees like
all the b1 and have that full
customization of your scholar you know
your subclass and man this thing could
be something so the reason why I'm
getting excited
normally with rumors like this I don't
but we have to look at the source right
this guy has predicted a lot of things
that have come true almost verbatim you
know I'm saying he leaked underlord
which we know is coming you know it's
like you said he almost has to be an
employee or a friend to the employee at
Bungie you know and I think this is
credible I think there's a lot you know
going on here that could be very true so
if this everything is true e where are
you at with the future of destiny
destiny 3 I mean for me these are these
are things that are like music to my
ears this is the type of stuff I want
because I want I mean I want those armor
sets that give set bonuses I want the
you don't like the mods to have even
more like why don't I just have a range
mod mm-hmm
why don't I have like actual numbers and
stats we can see hey the range kind of
goes up but you have to dive into a
database off game is range number is I'm
getting this green bar a little closer
but I can be like is that 90s that 92 is
that 87 is that I don't know I want
those knows details like if maybe even
this just takes me mouse over in it or
moving the cursor over it whatever it is
that's the type of stuff where it's
that's that's what I want to dive deeper
into and I think that will also for one
help the PC player base grow because
that
or of them would want and I think from
what they've seen like the longevity the
carrot on the stick has to be there in
this game if it's not there you have a
d2 situation where you lose a lot of the
ability of people to want to keep
playing I mean things like Red Dead are
gonna be anomalies that are going to
hold people away from this game no
matter what it is
I mean I'm even gonna try it and see
about doing some videos slowly for that
and that's just gonna be I'm trying to
actually not look too much of about that
but that's a thing I think I just want
to kind of experience that on my own and
see how it goes um there's always gonna
be big flight flagship things that will
steer way but it's the carrots on the
stick that give destiny the legs that it
had in d1 just like how did you get to
max level you had to raid that is
probably the most that's probably the
busiest lfg has ever ever been
continually like I mean yeah raid
launchers they're gonna get busy but as
people kind of get there and kind of die
off know like people really had to grind
their ass off for next level you had to
work your butt off for it yep so those
types of things the deeper they dive in
I've told you forever I want stats to
matter yes
I want those stats to have much heavier
weight if you're gonna go resilience and
you're gonna go recovering you're gonna
go those like give them wait let two
Titans of full recovery
maybe a level playing field with four
hunters with full mobility then they're
gonna be fast as hell and hard to hit
but they're gonna be tanky guys who's
sitting there together holding down a
fort and those four you know twitchy
hunters are gonna be hard to hit but
also a little little squishier like
that's all that's all the stuff I want
in this game and this is for me what
I've been waiting for and crossing my
fingers weak any wormhole
so any make sense it makes sense he
because if you look at forsaken right
forsaken is the real first Direction
change into of a more of a hardcore
version of this is it all the way no but
we definitely would say it's a it's it's
from all the things that David Sims a
minute they've made a you know I'm
saying matically they made a shift you
know as far as D the gameplay the grind
you know they were not as for
giving to the casual player as they've
normally been since the launch of d2 so
if this is the route man okay I'm ready
I'm with it big yeah I mean the other
piece I've seen people will say is like
you know you kind of want to get out of
the solar system I know everything keeps
coming to us or like venturing out to
Jupiter oh here's a different moon or
whatever it is it's like just somebody's
take on you know even just another
galaxy you're going between or just a
little farther outside bubbles mm-hmm
just outside of just the solar system
like expanding just keep expanding that
universe and that's how this is good
like spaces Internet I mean go have some
fun and like step outside of those boxes
and then you can get even more creative
with event space Doritos and hardcore
RPG I mean that's gonna be a lot to
swallow anyway
what I mean just just start opening up
the universe a little bit farther out
there I mean be really funny if there
was like on the non planet Pluto now up
there that you've got some random
outpost and all of a sudden you go in
there and there's some and that's kind
of a crazy thing so I mean you could
keep venturing out and doing things with
the solar system as it is but it'd be
kind of cool if you have to get like a
real warp drive and you travel between
that almost kind of changes the game a
little bit yeah as well because then you
were literally talking about like cross
galaxy we're going almost Star Trek at
that point you have it's like I'd like
it was like I see kind of as I said
there literally talk myself through that
it's like why they keep it solar system
cuz yeah you might have some warp but
you're not gonna go cross galaxy because
you might need a minute so mm-hmm
but yeah it's like it's there's I mean
you get into things work okay so here's
a question it's up if you can go and
this is why world Warcraft was kind of
one of those pieces if you can go light
or dark if you make one character light
your account is that way mmm interesting
that's cuz you either had to pick
hoarder alliance and if you pick one
hoard character and it would be on a
server you could go to a different
server and maybe try something else but
if you were on a server where your
friends are at you are all going to pick
either light or
our core horde or alliance and if you
bake like if you make a horde first
character your second character is going
to be horde so you're always against the
Alliance no matter what so I mean do you
think that's something they could ever
actually do now if you're interested if
they can implement it I'm not sure I'll
be listened to think the thing about the
three that is gonna be exciting is the
fact that by that point we're talking
next-gen ps5 Xbox to beefier PC hardware
both have got I mean I know what older I
know I'm gonna know we get boosts like
Xbox one X and ps4 perot-like those are
those are my generation yeah yeah
they're not like current tech right and
the main thing that's let's be honest
the main thing that's holding back which
was when D to launch and there was all
these rumors oh yeah the main thing is
the D CPUs are just in current consoles
are just you know to be able to handle
the frames per second now with the X
yeah they got the 4k Dan and with the
what's called checkerboarding and you
have very you know good resolutions and
I'm saying but at the end of the day you
want that 60 frames that crisp as you're
experiencing currently and you know it
definitely gonna be much beefier so I
can see that and then you're talking
about more CPU you talk about more
things on screen more matte more AI
computations so you know now we're
talking about possibly living breathing
world and I'm thinking about how like I
don't know if you caught the cyberpunk
demo did you catch that
oh sorry Punk is exactly winter 3 was
like kind of a game changer for that
studio so now you've got them doing
something that's gonna be mm-hmm
I mean they're trying to do an
open-world then you've got red I mean
both of those are gonna be those are
gonna be different yeah man so now
you're talking beefy hardware now you
really as a death can push pass
restriction you can push past them and
let's give them credit I mean I still
thought it was a gorgeous game I think
you know what they come sit in front of
my screen oh look better oh I see you
know I've seen it at you know at e3 I've
seen it at shows PC show I mean it looks
phenomenal you know it looks for it is a
beautiful game you know you're talking
about again
les AI restrictions and my last thing
they just got to do regardless to all
the graphical thing please for the love
of God let's get some dedicated servers
in de FEV p-please I mean just like
level the playing field that's like one
of the biggest things in flag because
like all I'm in mid-range like my KD a
is like 1.4 - I'm not amazing but I mean
I'm okay but I like the way my swings go
and how I'm playing and sometimes just
who I matched up against but there are
times when I just feel like I nail mine
and that other two other times I can't
and I know it's just it's gotta be that
damn connection because the way that I'm
still the same guy playing in two games
feel very different and it's just like
which side got the hosting and it's yeah
not mine that time when I'm losing and I
feel like that might be an excuse to
blame it on but like I still typically
play like it's gonna be the same load up
match to match and how's that swing so
hard for my ability to [ __ ] and
sometimes I may just get paired up with
people who are just awesome maybe but
that feeling of shots hitting or as I
think Wayne was screaming the other
night he's been on before yeah he
describes some people a slippery like
the bullets literally just want to like
slip like they're covered and a little
bit extra Teflon that day cuz you just
can't quite hit him as well and it's
just a little weird please come on out
list yeah craw all right cross
progression AHA yeah I think cross play
might be rough cuz I have so I thought
actually I had to calm myself down as a
tech I said wait a minute
there's still some technical hurdles not
saying that they can't do it but it will
be hard because remember because of
PlayStation exclusivity that messes
things up because there's certain
loopholes that can't be available and
what happens if you're a playstation guy
and you're taking you know what's the
current exclusive that they have right
now weapon wise linear if you the tracer
I don't know what it's called I don't
know what's call but less like he can't
go in a crucible match you know saying
with PC and Xbox because you don't mean
like how would that work
right I mean honestly you just have to
like if you're gonna go
I mean it's almost a point where you'd
either if the exclude wave splitter
think you like it
yeah you'd either have to gray it out
depending on what the matchmaking is
doing and say or it's just one of those
things for like playstation gonna be
like exclusives on or off or something
like that and that's who you're gonna
get matched up with and maybe if you do
want to open that pool you have to just
turn them off like but you don't yeah
but I'm saying you don't think by
default it would have to be off because
let's just say cuz you know the next
DLCs black arm we place yours gonna have
exclusive you know after the Joker's wow
they're gonna have like so as this goes
on right and we are assuming based on
history when d3 comes out PlayStation
this blood contract a big sign behind
the scenes about the rich shot out the
overage Hulk we had them on please did
you get a chance let's do that one yet
the whole one because I don't get to
like two or three behind on you here a
destiny listen the iron was podcast I'll
get you the number on the whole episode
was huge because he's a he's a gaming
corporate lawyer and I pressed them on
my bro I've never heard of a deal like
this in the history of gaming like
because normally you don't call a duty
they have a map pack for a month or two
you know if it's exclusive that kind of
deal right but I'm like this is like
this never-ending deal and he's like oh
yeah those things it's a give and take
he broke the whole thing down it is a
fantastic listen its LP 81 it's on the
iron Lords podcast
Richard Hogue of hole or this guy's a
gamer hardcore he does a lot of
corporate deals he understands contracts
all that kind of stuff and we do discuss
the strangeness and we went in depth of
that Activision / Sony / Bungie
relationship you know so this kind of
blows me away because Activision wants
battlenet how the PC doesn't get in the
I mean now you're gonna solve Xbox fans
but like Activision straight-up owns
like Blizzard battlenet I mean there are
that distributor so how do they not
broke it down with marketing pieces of
pie how much they're gonna get where
they gonna show it's really good man
I'll be 81 y'all get a chance go in
there check that bad boy out
a great interview with Hogan we
definitely discussed that topic
so basically come and bring this all in
which was um you know getting the d3 and
talking about cross play and talking
about how this thing could possibly work
and um yeah it might be like you said it
may be a thing where they just but if
they like night fold out like like they
what if they like Christy's night full
of the equipment lock where you just
have to grade out you'd have to do
something if you're gonna go play gambit
if you're gonna go play crucible if
you're gonna be in a PvP area where you
can't use that stuff or the exclusives
are gonna have to be like activities
that you can specifically go do a
Playstation people or you know cosmetics
that aren't gonna matter and you have to
get away from Game Change like you have
to get away from things that change
gameplay like weapons or armor you have
to get away from those pieces you have
to go more to other activities a special
mission or stuff like that I think that
might be where that would have to go to
bounce that stuff out because turning
stuff on and turning stuff off if you
have cross save like now if you have
cross savers cross play that's the
difference Cross saves literally if I'm
on PC or if I'm on PlayStation I switch
over to PC I just can't use it that's
like hey a box is grayed out okay that's
not that hard yeah but yeah cross play I
would say would be the harder thing to
balance cross save I think would be an
easier swing and I also think cross save
would be more logical because you have
I'm sorry if you are a console person
unless you're just a god you were gonna
get worked by somebody on a mouse and
keyboard that's just how that goes my
civility my able to control my abilities
those shots is the other piece why I
would say cross play is that one that
they probably don't want to breach cross
save yes cross play I don't see that I
think there's a shot man I still think
cross play is a shot only because with
Fortnight is groundbreaking the what for
tonight was able to do two on the Sony
side it showed that if you have a game
big enough with the magnitude and it's
hot and I feel destiny is of that level
you put d3 and ambitious d3 with no
limitations and all the stuff that we're
talking about and more graphics and more
CPU power for consoles and
with Xbox we'll talk about that on our
Peter Sunde you know they've just
allowed on mouse and keyboard support
you know I think this is like I think
the floodgate is about to open I don't
think it's gonna open for the rest of
this generation we may get one or two
examples but I think that um it's coming
because what's gonna happen II is that
they're gonna show the Microsoft's own
Microsoft is switching internals already
on board you know say they're gonna show
the Sony's and look by you restricting
this this is how much revenue you're
losing out look at now all these people
are buying Emoto all these people you
know have multiple copies of the game
and you're just creating constant
engagement that means Q sizes are bigger
and online polls you know we're not
trying to wait forever to get you know
match made and stuff like that that
could even help with something like a
guided games right
think about guided games now if you got
the communities of PC Xbox and
Playstation all searching how much more
helpful is that how much more thriving
is the game and I think they'll be able
to show Sony on the business side how
this is beneficial they prove that man
they back in biz man I think it's a
check I agree I think cross save is
probably more likely on the ranking
totem pole but I still think cross plays
got a shot I really do and how dope
would it be for you to just you know
said Rock Oh jumper declare let's go and
I've done it on I've done it on PC with
you know other games stated EK shouts
now the leaves in chat you know i i've
done that with him it's seamless man
it's literally flipping a switch and
within a three it's just a matter of now
besides that flipping the switch
building the game around it so
everything flows planning for it so yeah
I mean there's it's like destiny to is
in an amazing spot but looking that far
ahead is like man dreams and dreams may
come true like if they can nail like
we're talking about right now
shout out to likened by the way he's
like dude if I can't have facial hair in
d3 I'm gonna be pissed
you'll like is will fire but you have
little stuff like that to is like come
on character creator
and that maybe see and that's one of
those things like if you do D 3 do you
wipe out the vault all over again how do
you carry stuff forward if they do like
a light in the dark and characters and
changes and I think they got me an
excuse again I think they're gonna say
it we blew it up or something I'm glad
because they can't bring all these
weapons do you know how they do it again
but I'm okay with that I'm okay I mean
yeah I might be a little weird but it's
like honestly like every major expansion
of most other things you leave that you
should leave the old stuff behind
because I don't want to play with the
same gun for 10 years that's boring as
hell like who is already everybody's
hand kid and they're gonna use until the
end of d2 they just are like unless you
make a better version which maybe but
that one's just a guarantee and it's
just good um like I don't want to see
people carrying that just like the
Gjallarhorn didn't come for it even
though I heard icebreakers coming back
which I don't know how they're gonna
balance that thing oh my god
but generally to me like that full wipe
full clean slate like if you got to make
new characters you got to go light or
dark and that's gonna be the type of I
think change they need to justify that
so it is like I mean that might give
them a reason to do that
mm-hmm absolutely oh yeah escalation
shaadi yeah that just has to that can't
keep going nothing can't keep up with
that no shot and it's not even that is
your only PvE shotgun yeah that's it
that is your only one I am worried about
that weapon weapon is just so good that
it's really tough to I mean the only gun
right now that semi competes with it in
PvE now come nothing competes with it
the only gun that I've been used with
like a yeah is a age-old bond the
curator oh that's only because I got
this curated role and it's still not
just I just got to have accurate it role
and then in PvP I just happen to have a
really good calls it a wolf but if I
didn't even so I mean EP shotgun is just
good for everything it's just it's so
damn good it's a legendary man it almost
reminds me of the black hammer days when
he such a good legendary this like how
would I even think about taking this out
the slot
yeah I mean it's just like that's the
stuff and that's why somebody's like oh
I love me pee shadi yes Chris Cober you
do but it's like the game needs to
evolve and if you keep using the same
shotgun for forever it old like
everybody used Gjallarhorn for long as
it could do it they even brought it back
in d2 which I saw that was a mistake but
generally for me that's that that's why
those big resets are good that's why
those large expansion moments need those
slate cleaners because you have to get a
fresh set of stuff you have to give me
the reason to grind up give me new
exotics to find find all those reasons
to make me love the new game not wish it
was the old or wish I could just wait to
infuse my new one up absolutely uh
that's about two hours guys so I was
like it's been I was like I feel like we
could just keep speculate on this stuff
forever long but awesome chat this
morning guys thank you life for you guys
if you don't catch these you can always
check them on I love pod cast iron I
love pod cast iron Morgan Fox iron Lords
podcast you can check it on there I'll
get it uploaded to mine as well Caesar
on mine thank you everyone recently for
the support on everything Mitch YouTube
like literally it was a month and I
doubled that what I literally doubled my
subs because I went from 10,000 I broke
it on September 24th 24th I broke twenty
thousand I was just like what is
happening I don't like and there was a
it was just like there's little people
like I've had it a couple times more
frequently just somebody on PC not the
biggest player base in the world but
like adds me as a friend I'm just like I
don't care all at them and they're like
are you like the ebon to some place oh
you're good I got a couple of those I'm
like dude you're making me blush over
here okay I will say one video that hits
like 450,000 people I guess there's odds
for its gonna be there but I mean
honestly like I'm that's kind of why I
put the tweet out to thank everyone
because like
you know that was hashtag humbled for me
yes it's crazy to me legs and I thank
you guys for the support I know
everybody's like hey you got good
content you do good things like it's
just one of these hobbies I try and do
and it's just like my things I feel like
I'm too long-winded I like it
say too many things and then like you
guys come in and so I appreciate all the
support I can't thank everybody enough
like twitch bruh I'm like I was like 500
followers after my giveaway now I'm up
like 700 followers got a couple subs on
to which recently thank you guys for the
support they're the wart you guys are
all awesome to both sides as well and
anybody who's new to likey my world of
ebon says go share the love over to iron
Lords podcast let's both just absolutely
the deep dives they do and that's what
he's talking about Richard how can that
like interview the the long-form podcast
I know ours is long-form it's just two
people ramble you guys put up with a lot
mm-hmm
interviews that you get on there the
guest that you have the deep dives that
you guys go into are ones that anyone as
who likes tech who like who enjoys video
games and just enjoys this whole entire
entertainment venue in general you get
into some great discussions in there for
you guys and if you enjoy the long-form
if that's your thing and you're here
anyway like go join another one I mean
it's it's a good one it's up though you
the passion is there because the
laughter is real oh they lose their
minds sometimes but that's when you if
you're in that moment you will listen to
liked in later and somebody's busting
out laughing I'm laughing in my car -
its it's good stuff so I was like yeah
thank you guys but also like yeah spread
that level over there I want to I want
to see them explode - because I don't
work
yeah man listen first of all congrats to
you again man to see like I said that
jump for the 20 G's was just super
impressive and I got told you that you
know we talk offline couldn't have
happened to like a cooler person like
you understand the monsters you get here
is to say indie bondage you get in real
life and that's not a lot I can say on a
lot of content creators that I've come
across you look at some people fake but
we ain't gonna get him in but uh but now
he boxes is the real deal he's true blue
proud to call my friend just to see your
journey like it's just to see this
growth and you hitting it man
hitting it really hard to see the
support it is well well the serve so
that is dope man and I said oh god I
gotta get you back on our lap I figure
we'll work towards black arm Raylan yeah
III I mean wow hopefully that yeah
before you'll be way before I don't
believe before many times before that
but yeah right front run around like a
d2 release like a black Romney I think
it'd be good timing like black armor is
gonna be a big tell for the in you like
the future honestly yes because that's
gonna tell like what does this annual
pass actually look like and if they can
do that well that really gives me a lot
of faith for your future so yeah those
post black armor released yeah see if
you can pencil me in there once we know
anything absolutely man
yeah but yeah thank you guys it's been
awesome chat this morning live thank you
for all the support those Lords podcast
on both sides all that man's got me like
yeah but you got me smoke don't put her
man you got like thousands of people's
tweets getting a lot of love so always
an awesome morning thank you guys all
for chat follow its abundance everywhere
twitch Twitter YouTube subscribe follow
the Chris code real quick he said great
greatest podcast of Friday rolling for
the flashpoint that's what's up Chris
coming out really really means a lot to
us like I said this was a passion
project and I reached out to my man
Yvonne says you know no one loves
Destiny's boys they're meeting him and
you know we started and it probably had
the worst time ever to do a podcast yeah
but uh like 37 weeks you're like what
were you guys doing in jail why I listen
to those always they're funny and we
just love this game and we still talk
about it and just to see this journey to
see the transformation of the game to
actually be coming to this great place
once again it feels good and it feels
good that took me out look at it like it
feels good that we stayed loyal to the
game yeah in a sense you know at the end
of the day we did get rewarded things
happen it can fall off again but you
know yeah definitely like to make our
critiques and
you know and even Bungie couple times
maybe took a little downs units and
stuff like that so that was cool
so let's the flashpoint man that's where
you guys first meet you know obviously
you know at more kognito on twitter same
thing on xbox and playstation I'm
actually gonna switch over I've copied
over 360 there but I actually gonna do
the PlayStation name change when given
time you know make myself look you know
there as well and as you know every
Sunday is the Lord's Day and back on the
iron Lord podcast channel so you don't
have two channels to go back and forth
with it's just iron law podcast YouTube
channel we will go live Sunday at 11
a.m. Eastern we have one of the most
positive guys in the gaming community je
Fonzarelli good youtuber good co-creator
and we will be talking some Red Dead
Redemption he's a big Red Dead
Redemption fan so we get into that we
also have some great topics in gaming of
what's going on so catch the Lords on
Sunday 11 a.m. Eastern on our podcast
YouTube channel it is the Lord's Day
yeah so that's it for us guys thank you
guys we went over two hours because I
kind of thought that speculation might
go a little long so we didn't track two
hours but thank you guys for sticking
with us always a great morning with all
of y'all and just enjoy it out there
there's a lot of fun
if you got to take a break play some Red
Dead do that have some fun just enjoy
your days enjoy your gaming and enjoy
your weekend
whatever you guys do have some fun oh
and one other thing I don't care how you
do it just go vote yeah do that your
civic duty if you're in the u.s. go vote
other than that that's all I got so
thank you guys very much and I think
we'll see you guys soon
whether it's a twitch stream whether
it's iron Lord podcasts next week we'll
see you soon I'll be back next Friday
have a good one guys
you